you know what you did where is the scene
of that we are at the seat of that and I
know I never did anything but that's we
a little bit miss Lauren Conrad did you
ask for her blessing did you talk to her
before agreeing to do the show I didn't
talk to her um but I feel like I talked
to someone that knows her and I think
that she was still really excited for us
all to do it and she's in such a
different place of her life you know
like I think she's probably just feeling
like I don't know she's about to have a
baby like want some quiet time at home
I'm sure hopefully she'll watch and be
entertained by it I actually did Lauren
is a really close friend of Jennifers
and uh I heard she she I think she wants
what's best for us I think she's that
kind of person she wishes me the best on
this she I think being against the show
I think she just she's moved on to
bigger better things no you know I for
me is because everybody's in such a
different state in their life the big
focus was for me is like I want to focus
on my family I'm married I have a kid
now and and you know which are obviously
the best of luck and she's doing great
and you know congratulations to her and
her family but you know I really kept it
to us and what we're doing possible I
don't think anyone did no one's really
talked her through this finale I know
Frankie has but so we all would our
complete separate ways no I haven't
talked to Lauren and quite some time
it's been I don't know years I run into
her every few years here and there to
stand her out it's tough but
no we didn't not it
[Music]